c'est le dernier grand chantier dans le
domaine de l'art moderne en france avant
l'an 2000 en tout cas il s'agit du musée
qui va être inaugurée vendredi demain à
strasbourg un musée d'art moderne et
contemporain qui va regrouper des
connexions très dispersées jusqu'à
présent c'est là le résultat de dix
années de travail reportage signé
antoine cormery jean pierre halter juste
avant l'ouverture les derniers
préparatifs vont bon train avec deux
questions clés le tableau est il bien
droit voilà c'est la décaler légèrement
sur le préfet et la sculpture vraiment
bien à sa place
il est sûr qu'une havre l1 son lieu et
vous le sentez un certain moment elle
s'est juste ans et ça c'est quelque
chose qui n'a rien à voir avec le
mauvais goût mais avec peut-être
l'expérience
voici le nouveau musée d'art moderne et
contemporain de strasbourg signée de
l'architecte adrien fainsilber granit
rose acier et verre
voilà dix ans que ce projet chiffré à
235 millions de francs a été lancé pour
permettre à la ville de se mesurer aux
grands musées de l'allemagne voisine est
exposé et enfin dans de bonnes
conditions l'une des plus belles
collections françaises mon souci et je
le dis au quotidien aux conservateurs et
de faire en sorte que ce musée ne soit
pas réservé à quelques-uns à une petite
élite mais qu'il soit aussi ouvert que
possible sur un public large pour lui
faire goûter
l'art contemporain est aussi pour lui
permettre d'avoir un lieu de vie en
quelque sorte ici à strasbourg
supplémentaire au mur donc les plus
grandes stars de l'art moderne mené
champs de coquelicots 10 890 clint
sensuelle aquarelles de 1909
pucca et son provoquant rouge à lèvres
1908 ou alpes
l'enfant du pays largement représentés
ici à strasbourg
mais le musée condensé d'orsay de
beaubourg fait aussi la part belle à
l'art contemporain buren lavier mort et
les sont à découvrir dans d'immenses
salles baigné de lumière que les
peintres en bâtiment s'est promis vont
enfin abandonné au peintre d'aujourd'hui